you guys
yes hello everyone and welcome to
today's
live broadcast improvements to bile
collection studies
in rats i'm susie valdez of labrutz and
i will be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by
sai infusion technologies for more
information about our sponsor please
visit their site
at sai hypheninfusion.com
so let's get started i want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time during the presentation to
do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click
send if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
just click on the support tab found at
the top
right of your presentation window or
report your problem by clicking
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
i'd now like to introduce our presenter
merrill cramer from dmpk
and sampling specialist at sai
and brad gene the global head of surgery
and in vigo
and gina ma scientist one in in vivo
pharmacology at vividian
therapeutics for a complete biography of
our presenter please visit the biography
tab at the top of your screen
merrily you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone thank you susie as susie
mentioned i'm meryl cramer and i'm the
dmpk
and sampling specialists for sai
infusion technologies
in case you're not familiar with sai we
specialize in
catheters infusion and sampling we're
the industry leader in catheter
technology and research
including everything from rounded tip
catheters for
maximum patency to pumps
today we're very lucky to have these two
extremely qualified professionals on
board to help us with different aspects
of a successful bile study
brad is the global head of surgery for
invigo and will be sharing his extensive
knowledge of bile duct catheterization
surgery and recovery
gina is a scientist at vividian
therapeutics and she will be sharing
some of her first-hand experience
running biostudies in the lab thank you
so much for sharing
your expertise brad and tina
today's webinar will be a top-level
overview of bile collection studies with
a deep dive
into surgery directed mainly towards
people who are new to this model
however even a seasoned pro will find
some useful information in here
it will take about an hour and we've
broken it down into these six
sections we'll begin by providing
rationale for running a bile study
then move on to discuss best practices
when implanting catheters and running a
study
finally we provide information on the
equipment you need to get started
and some tips and tricks to help
navigate complications and
ensure success
so what is file where do you get it why
do we need it
if you never thought too much about bio
and decided to look it up online
you would find some very interesting
information from some very interesting
disciplines
for instance yellow bile is one of the
four gallenic humors developed by
hippocrates
and if you only looked up the definition
you would see that although bile is a
luminous gold color
the choleric temperament doesn't have
the most glowing reputation
then again if you've ever been
frustrated by a bile collection study
you might agree that these definitions
do kind of encapsulate the bile study
experience
luckily we're here to tell you how to
redefine that experience
into one not nearly so angry and gloomy
speaking of defining here are the most
important definitions to know when
running bile studies
i call these the abcd of bile
thorough profiling of novel compounds
centers on adenine
this is the absorption distribution
metabolism and excretion profile of the
parent compound
which is what you dosed and its
metabolites which are generated by
metabolism of the parent compound
mainly in the liver the basics of a bile
collection study or a bdc study
involve surgically implanting
purpose-built catheters
into both the bile duct and the duodenum
these catheters are externalized and
connected to create an external loop
which shunts the outgoing bile from the
bile duct
back down and into the duodenum this
recirculation of bile provides the
animal with
violent needs while recovering from the
catheter implantation surgery
this surgical preparation along with the
dosing and collection of bile required
can be intricate and technically complex
therefore bile studies are only run when
the data they provide is necessary to
proceed with compound profiling
the investigation of these
pharmaceuticals or agrochemicals
which are in discovery and development
generally involves investigating
metabolism and excretion of the
compounds in urine and feces
however it's often necessary to
determine the excretion of
compound-related material in the bile
especially where enterohepatic
recirculation may occur
bdc studies help determine the level of
excretion of test compounds into the
bile
or the effect of the test compound on
the physiological system
overall bdc studies help us to
understand a compound's kinetic profile
in particular the excretion phase which
you may remember
puts the e in add me and bile studies
are frequently required to
as you see on the slide comply with
regulatory guidelines
better understand a compound with
unusual pk
to further evaluate specific types of
compounds
or to create a stronger base of data for
future studies
okay we know we need to run these
studies
but what information will be gained as i
mentioned
bdc studies inform admin which is a
regulatory requirement
and right before excretion is metabolism
and most metabolism occurs in the liver
and one of the liver's principal
functions is the formation of bile
which is requisite for the digestion of
fat and the elimination of drugs and
metabolites
hepatic metabolism is an important
determinant of drug clearance and
bioavailability
and as we know rats are frequently the
first species used to characterize drug
clearance and bioavailability
and because rats slack gallbladders they
are ideal models for examining
biliary drug disposition
so this isn't a clinical science talk
so here's just one quick example of a
time when running a bile study is well
worth the time and the effort
when generic companies are trying to
prove bioequivalence between their
generic drug and the current drug on the
market
they want to demonstrate that their
generic drug is highly soluble and
highly permeable
this is normally done in a caico2 cell
assay
however caico2 cells will not work on
compounds which undergo efflux
luckily our bile rats can demonstrate
that permeability
or lack thereof readily so in the case
where the generic drug is shown to be a
class 1
which is both highly soluble and highly
permeable
the generic company can obtain a bcs
class one waiver
and save millions of dollars in
development of course this is a great
motivation
to run a successful bile study
and that is just one example of a time
when you would
run one so now we have an example of
why we might want to run a biostudy but
the question remains how do we do it
and how do we do it successfully here
are the six steps look how easy i make
it look
six simple steps but those of you who
are already familiar with bio collection
studies can probably attest to how
challenging these steps can actually be
from the surgery to the collection this
is a demanding model
thankfully sai has some suggestions that
can revolutionize your biostudy
experience
and speaking as someone who has run
countless biostudies myself
the bile setup from sai is a real game
changer
so here is brad to tell you about the
first two steps which are the surgery
and recovery
please take it away brad
good morning everyone i am going to talk
a little bit about the bile duct surgery
process
i have completed thousands of these
surgeries and
in video we've completed tens of
thousands of these surgeries
uh i'm gonna rather quickly through it
because i do have a lot of information
and um they
may i do not have four or five hours to
present i have to get through this in
about 30 minutes
so we'll uh move through this fairly
quickly
today we're going to talk about bile
duct waffle loop surgery
so where we're looping it from the uh
about
around the back of the animal back into
the duodenum
basically making an extension of the
bile duct
for sampling as part of the surgery
technique
we have found it best that rats will be
over 250 grams at the time of the
surgery
not to say that we haven't done smaller
animals and
mice as well but for rats we find they
thrive best if they're over 250 grams
275 to 325 grams is optimal for
surgery some of the surgery preparation
is you want to make sure that you have
the correct surgical instruments and
supplies
my fancy animation supplies that we use
for uh bile duct surgery are
filling up now not gonna go through
every single uh
thing on the list you're welcome to
review this and and pause it and
look at what we have on it's very
important you have the right instruments
when you go to do the surgery
uh i've seen many times people starting
or i'm training them on surgery without
the right instrument
and bio surgery is already very
difficult
and with instruments makes it even that
much harder
uh part of the surgery prep for us is
catheter choice and this really matters
starting 20 years ago i built my own
catheter
and wasn't good at it i discovered how
difficult it is to build a good quality
the correct size material and design of
catheter
which is why we went to
professionals at sai to have them custom
make our
bile duct duodenal catheters we found
that three french
which is rather large and and slightly
more difficult to get into a ball duct
provides the best level and matches the
interior size of a bile duct
in a rat the size that we're using
we made a little eater we put a bevel on
the bile duct end using
medical grade polyurethane so it's not
that stiff
but stiff enough that it doesn't just
kink
every time we put it in your other
options
polyethylene which is is much too stiff
and can damage the bile duct
or silicone which uh any of you that
have used silicone before
those is kinks over on itself fairly
readily and
is is much more difficult to work with
these circumstances
weave the bead on the dwelling lens and
use a purse string suture to put it in
um immediate
pre-surgical prep continuing
uh you want to look at the analgesic
dancing and you want to dose at
pre-surgery we found that to be the best
using inhalation anesthesia to be the
best
we have done both injectable and
inhalation
and we always pre-dose with analgesics
before surgery we tend to use a
buprophen
and we've started using the wonderful
extended
release buprenorphine from fidel and
also
maloxicam on board as well
we weigh shave and and disinfect the
skin pre-surgically
and uh then we use a septic surgical
technique
we complete the surgery in a dedicated
surgery area
this can be anywhere that's kind of a
low traffic area
we worked in several labs where it's
been a table
not necessarily in the lunchroom but
very close to it to where we have now
dedicated surgery buildings
um they're very low traffic we have
positive air pressure and airflow
which keeps that area clean uh
surgery sport technicians are great i
consider them kind of the backbone of
the operations there by
you know supporting the surge
and having a safe heat source computer
and maintain the animal's body
temperature during surgery
is also very important sterilize the
surgical instruments
without sterile instruments for any
surgery you're going to have
infection or complications and uh
sterilized catheters
and uh we tend to use a lot of the
capture access buttons for these
surgeries
you want to make sure you have a clean
area around the surgery in your surgery
area so you're not setting your
instrument down in a
area or touching dirty areas and then
bringing that to the animal
you want to make sure that your surgeons
are trained and certified
and they have a comfortable chair every
time i put this
in i have to make sure they have
comfortable chair or comfortable shoes
if they're standing some people like
myself
that are getting old eyes
require a microscope and music
more definitely
so there's two methods that i've trained
on in surgery
uh one method we do not use anymore
it's where we make a rather large
abdominal incision
we remove the abdominal contents locate
the bile duct and insert the catheter
locate the duodenum and insert the other
end of the catheter
tunnel the catheters and then kind of
put all the
abdominal contents back into the animal
and finish by sewing up everything very
important during that
surgical procedure you keep the
abdominal contents
very moist and you're not letting it dry
out
a much improved procedure in my opinion
would be
more of a keyhole surgery so we make a
very small
1.5 to 2 centimeter incision directly
above the bile duct
we use sterile saline soaked untipped
applicators to
gently move the liver liver out of the
way we locate the bile duct insert a
catheter
locate the duodenum and insert the other
end of the catheter tunnel
catheters and then close the
abdominal wound this
is much more efficient this is much
preferred for the animal as well because
you're not
opening up such a large incision and
removing the abdominal contents
and this is going to be the procedure
that we go through
step by step very quickly
again because of time constraints
so this is kind of a standard operating
surgical procedure for us that we tend
to follow
and train our surgeons on so
catheterization the bile duct we like to
go
through you know having two sets of
instruments for the surgery one
designated for
outside the animal or the skin and one
set of instruments designated for
subcutaneous tissue are inside the
animal so that we can keep
the uh aseptic technique intact
so first we would make that incision in
the
muscle and skin and muscle
and then we would puncture through the
muscle wall on
outside of where the
um of where the incision is
so as not to have the catheters exiting
the muscle through the same incision
that we're going to actually complete
the insert the catheters
this helps the muscle incision heal a
lot better and a lot faster
as well as um the catheters aren't uh
free and moving they're actually quite
tight within the muscles so that they
can't be pulled
out if the animal moves in a certain
direction or
if the researcher happens to pull up on
the catheter
from outside the animal so we do have
fixed costs on the catheter they're
placed inside the abdominal
cavity which also helps hold them uh
inside the muscle wall
we try to avoid suturing anything to the
muscle wall
it does cause irritation as well
uh so once we have the catheters in
place
we locate the bile duct and gently
elevate the bile duct
and if you make your incision correctly
the bile duct is
right there there's no missing it these
incisions
in these pictures again keep in mind and
the drape
being there in one pit and removed in
the other
are for demonstration purposes and
training purposes so the incisions are a
little bit larger and the drape is
missing in some of the pictures so that
we could get a
better visualization of the surgery
so you can see in the top right hand
corner a close-up of the elevated bowel
duct
and keep in mind the bile duct is not
as elastic as it appears
in these pitchers or as a jugular vein
or carotid
would would be in a normal vascular
surgery
so you have to be very careful not to
pull
or stretch that duct too much
we place a ligature around the duct
and a ligature very near the duodenum
and we place slight slight tension on
the the bile duct end of the literature
while we're inserting the catheter
so using micro scissors or a needle i
prefer a
a small gauge needle but using micro
scissors
are a small gauge needle you can make
a small uh hole
into the bile duct and you implant the
bile duct
belt end part of the catheter into the
duct
you would bring your loose ligature on
the cranial side of the duct
which will hold in your bile duct
catheter
the bile should be observed flowing
immediately and easily through the
catheter
so once you remove once you remove
your elevator
you'll see bowel flowing freely into the
catheter
you do want to make sure that you do tap
off that
or use a hemostat to
[Music]
crimp the catheter so as to not have
bile duct free flowing out
that you still haven't implanted into
the duodenum
so once you excuse me
once you remove and and you've blocked
off the bile
you've made sure the bottle is flowing
blocked it off you start your
catheterization of the duodenum
the catheterization of the duodenum is
much easier than than finding and
categorizing the bile duct so this
procedure should take you a couple
minutes to get done
you want to place your forceps at the
tip of the pyloric sphincter
and you want to put in a purse string
suture into the duodenum
being mindful to stay away from any
vessels that you can visually see
once you purse string suture in the
duodenum
right in the center of that perspective
you're going to use a clean sterile
needle we use a 16 or 18 gauge needle
depending on surgeon preference and
you're going to
put the needle in and as you're removing
the needle
you're going to be sliding the duodenal
catheter
at the same time you're going to discard
that needle it's a simple use only
obviously
since we are putting it into the
duodenum
and you're going to continue advancing
the catheter until you push through the
first
of two fixed beads the idea is you're
going to have one fixed bead inside the
door
and one fixed bead on the outside of the
duodenum so that when you tighten that
purse string stitcher you have a good
clean
duodenal area so that no leakage will
come from the duodenum you want to make
sure that you drop the bottom around the
sutures
and apply one to two tiny cups of tissue
adhesive
i can't i guess emphasize enough that
you want as
little tissue adhesive as possible i've
seen
certain animals where it looks like
they've used a bottle of tissue adhesive
and you have kind of everything stuck
together inside
we attach a small gauge blunt tip needle
to the end of our tissue glue
and place one drop of tissue glue just
over to make sure that that
hole in the duodenum is perfectly sealed
before moving on
we do have the the two beads on there as
well that do
ensure a good seal the other option
catheters that i've used before do have
a mesh on them
we've we've had good success with the
mesh as well
it's just not preferred for us in this
surgery we did
increase adhesion using it so we moved
away from it and stuck with a purse
suture but the mesh still will work
once the adhesive is dry that's kind of
key you got to wait for the heat
to dry and in this picture i will say it
does need to be replaced
because that is a little much adhesive
hiking but
uh once the adhesive is dried then you
would
release your elevator which is the the
sterile
saline soaked cotton tip applicator
and you would flush the catheter with a
little bit of sterile water just to
ensure that there are no loops
from your string suture or glue you
return the duodenum
back to the natural position and you
exteriorize the catheter
what we like to do is put a little bit
of baitrol
uh into the abdominal cavity an ip
injection
and i think i say this on a later too um
you shouldn't use a whole lot of
antibiotic
in this case to compensate for poor
surgery technique you
you want to make sure that your surgery
that is clean and
everything is as aseptic as possible we
do
only give a single dose of the
antibiotic this time
uh once you you trocar the
catheters to the between the shoulder
blades of the animal
we use staples to close the skin
incision
we close the muscle incision with
sutures close the incision with staples
because the animals tend to get
at that incision and then we exteriorize
the catheters between the shoulder
blades
standard clothing for us is using a
stainless steel tube to connect the
the the fixed catheters between the
shoulder blades
um obviously we first make sure that we
have bowel flowing
and that the duodenal end of the
catheter is primed
if there's a lot of air in the duodenal
end of the catheter we find the bile
will come
flow through so you want to make sure
that's primed and creating a siphon-like
action
to get the bile flowing through the
catheter
that's extending your blood here's kind
of a finished of a fixed
catheter uh bottle duct
which we used to do a little bit and
we're connecting buttons to these
um which uh maryland and they're gonna
continue to talk about
moving forward into a couple of
slideshow for an exteriorization
options uh nothing is more exciting to
me and to the surgeons at this point
when you have nice bright yellow balls
flowing through your
catheter we do a
number you can do a number of different
exteriorizations
the stainless steel connector again is
probably i started in 99
of the surgeries i did early on were
that way we did a few harnesses
and we moved on now and we've done a lot
of buttons the button is really
convenient because
internal studies and some external
researchers that we've partnered with
have been able to keep their ball duct
animals around for
30 days or longer doing studies on
monday tuesday and walking them out and
then redoing some studies in the
following week
we kept animals in-house for 30 days
and uh we did not see much uh bile duct
engorgement there was a little but not
much
and we only looked at the animals once a
week and flushed the duodenal end to
stop the
flip of bile salts in that end of the
catheter and took a small sample of bile
just to make sure that we still had
bowel flowing
the buttons and caps allow group housing
which helps in recovery a lot these
animals are
are very well recovered a five-day
post-op
which is a very impressive compared to
when
when we started doing these surgeries in
our lab
many years ago
and the caps also have a handy little
um window there that you can actually
watch your ball flowing
if you have uh if you have good enough
eyes
we'll talk a little bit about recovery
welfare and patency checks so
depending on exteriorization still
housed if there's exposed catheters of
course because you do not want uh
the animals that they're sharing a cage
with to
to chew on the catheters there's nothing
disappointing than coming in and
having a disconnect bile duct catheter
or chewed catheter
and paired housings with the catheter
access button
and the caps the recirculation caps
this is a preferred force again because
of animal welfare reasons we do see
quite an increase in
decreasing recovery time and increase in
better health
alter of the animals and we also
are able to run more studies
contributing to the three r's
on the same set of animals rather than
doing new surgery around every set of
animals
we do supplemental heating post surgery
24 to 72 hours
along with our sustained release of
buprenorphine
and we put soft food on the cage floor
which we replace frequently
the animals will step in it it'll spill
it'll
it'll spoil quickly so we do soft
food and gel foods on the floor of the
cage in a
little uh dish for them
uh i don't know about uh after surgery i
don't feel like reaching up to grab my
food i'd rather have it
close to me and we do a lot of frequent
welfare checks on these
animals being that it is under surgery
minimally it's twice a day but we do
check
them probably four or five times a day
during the first 24 to 48 hours we try
our hardest
not to take them out
of the cage because
major abdominal surgery i wouldn't want
to be picked up
and manipulated so we try to leave them
in their home cage we do
weigh them and make sure to do a full
clinical observation panel on them
and if there is a problem then yes we
will take them out of the cage and
either offer them more treatment
or warm fluid injections um
so we we again try to let them get
comfortable
in our cages we
observe bowel flow try observe it every
day
sometimes immediately post surgery
you're going to see the boss
up and we've attributed that to kind of
the
uh spasm of the bile duct or the
you know just the shock of putting in a
bile duct catheter
we leave them for a few days and then
we'll look at them again and
again in a few animals per thousand
we're going to see positional problems
with the catheter
just hasn't been laid in the abdomen
correctly and it may be kinked or when
the animal
rolls up to sleep it kind of prevents
flow
but the most part once the the
animal is has had a couple of days to
recover you do see
normal bowel flow
all right sorry
so animal water so we we switched
surgeries from removing everything from
the abdomen
to just this keyhole surgery because we
wanted to
reduce internal organ adhesions in all
surgeries of course you can have
adhesions which
but we wanted to minimize it as much as
possible
because we even cause pain they can
lower the catheter patency as well
we wanted to make sure that all surgeons
that do this
are updated in their training and
methods for doing it
and have the right equipment and
instruments um
less is best again lower amounts of
surgical manipulation
is a lot better than you know removing
everything from
from the abdomen so we started doing
keyhole surgery
that's where we saw a great increase in
patency
and something that uh you know
early on i didn't think about we want to
we wanted to look at again less foreign
so we cut down our suture tags down
lower
um it matters and put in five or six
different suture points or
sutures into the muscle if it wasn't
needed we don't do it
powder free gloves which i think almost
everyone is using or
hopefully should be using especially for
surgery are washing the powder off
we saw some horrible infections uh
long before i told viggo with powdered
gloves going directly into animals
and just infection control so you want
to make sure that you don't have any
bile or duodenal leakage
um anyone that's done the surgery if you
have any bowel leakage or duodenal
leakage you know that
is kind of a very
serious endpoint for that subject
we we came up with flushing the
abdominal
cavity immediately post surgery with
warm saline and kind of
flush it and dump it out and [ __ ] it
again so that we can uh
minimize any feeds that we maybe didn't
see at the time of the surgery
pain see so we can attain several weeks
of patency with good surgical technique
and
replacement and uh but again like i said
earlier bile duct patency can maintain
for long periods of time
uh without any duct engorgement and
without any ill effects to the animal
uh what can affect poor surgical
techniques is probably the biggest thing
that i saw
adhesions which come with the an excess
suture materials
incorrect are our wrong use of surgical
instruments
and just surgeon practice uh it is true
what they say practice
you you do get better with practice or
your parents probably told you practice
makes perfect
um it is true uh cathode replacement so
where will you place the catheter in the
bottle that
matter where you place it in the
duodenum matters and placement how you
lay it in the
after you go through all that work of
getting you know your perfect ball flow
and great placement in the duodenum
i've seen a lot of people just kind of
shove it into
into the abdomen or
subcutaneously when they're powering it
just kind of put it
wherever and uh they get cancer
they get many many other issues so so
it's important even
all details on these major surgeries
catheter size you want to match
all ducks bias it's always easier to put
in a very small catheter into the bile
duct
and you're going to see bile duct
engorgement and flow issues
you want to make sure that you have
continuous flow and have as few catheter
junctions as possible the more glued
jungle
you have is more uh points that the
catheter could fail or leak
uh and decrease surgery time you know
less time on the table is better
surgical
but you definitely don't want to replace
the quality with a
sigma surgery um quality is obviously
going to be the most important
but you don't want to have a two hour
bile duct surgery versus where it should
be taking you between
20 and 25 minutes for a ball duck
surgery
now i think this is the end of me yes it
is this is
uh where i pick up again so thank you so
much brad that was
fantastic i actually i've done quite a
few of these surgeries myself
and i still learned a lot from those
slides
so now that everyone knows how to put
the catheters in
let's talk about how to safely and
efficiently
access the bile once the animal has
recovered
so earlier i said that surgery is the
first step in the bile study but that's
not actually true
before the surgery you need to choose
the proper catheter and
as brad mentioned that catheter choice
really matters
because any catheter i study
is going to hinge on three factors and
that is the catheter
the surgery and the maintenance it
doesn't matter how good
any two of those are if the other one is
no good
you are not going to have a patent
animal that goes for
any catheterized study so when you're
choosing your catheter you should be
aware that catheter design
can include specialized tips feeds for
anchoring
fenestrations all kinds of things and
these options are all designed to
facilitate access to the appropriate
vessels and
for bile surgery sai has a variety of
options and they're designed to meet the
needs of the surgeons who are implanting
these catheters
but overall each catheter is going to
have a very small tip
in order to access the very small and
friable
bile duct as brad explained we recommend
a medical grade polyurethane catheter
because polyethylene is a bit too stiff
and silicone
is a bit too flexible so medical grade
polyurethane is definitely
the way to go and of course we can
provide
a three french medical grade pu
catheter that has a beveled tip on the
violin and a bead on the duodenal end
or we can customize the catheter further
for what your surgeon requires for the
duodenal catheter you can either implant
using the pur string suture
as brad described or you could select a
catheter with mesh on the end
so that you can secure it in place with
a tiny tiny
amount of vet bond or another sterile
tissue glue
but once you've selected the proper
catheter for your surgery
and your catheters are placed and
externalized properly
the way brad explained uh you have a few
options when it comes to connecting
the bile circuit externally
and here is a illustration of three of
them
so the first one is you simply
externalize the bile duct and duodenal
catheters and connect them with a
stainless steel connector until you're
ready to go
brad showed a picture of that and as you
mentioned
that's how many surgical vendors
complete their bile loops before
shipping their animals
they used to always do that but times
have changed
some people still get their animals this
way because they're collecting bile
intermittently
while the animal is anesthetized or if
they're using an auto sampler such as
the basic
lex the issue here with this connection
is that you need to manipulate
a very small and very slippery connector
or pin
as well as the catheter which is
continually leaking slippery soapy bile
and because of this pins can easily slip
out of the catheter
leading to lost samples and potentially
lost animals
which is is awful because
obviously you don't want to lose any
animals but also now you're down an
animal and you spend a lot of money and
time and
you want to avoid losing a catheter
connection
at all costs the next option the second
picture is the harness
and if you receive your animals with the
externalized catheters that i just
described from the first picture
you can apply this harness to your
animal in-house
vendors are happy to put it on for you
before they ship the animals if you want
and that may be preferable since
attaching the harness requires
connecting those same slippery catheters
to the pins on the underside of the
harness but once applied the connection
is protected by the dome of the harness
and the catheters can be accessed
through the ports on the harness
these harnesses are available in one two
or three ports
and they're affordable a short tether is
used to recirculate the bile
and while on study these animals can be
hooked up to a quick connect tether
for a secure long-term bile collection
however
you need to be diligent about adjusting
the tension of the harness to ensure
a proper fit as the animal moves grows
loses weight you need to adjust the
tension on
the belly band to make sure that the
calf that the harness is sitting
properly
finally the third option is the button
that we've been
discussing your surgical vendor can
implant that cannulac button during the
catheterization surgery
and with this button up to three
catheters can be securely attached to
the unique barbed candy lock pins which
are underneath the skin
these connections are well protected and
extremely secure
to recirculate the vial you simply place
that shunting cap that you saw earlier
on the button and this cut this cap pops
right on
and attaches magnetically for an
extremely easy
quick and secure recirculation of the
bile
the rats can then co-house while
recovering from surgery
and that of course is a major refinement
for animal welfare
and then when you're ready to begin your
study you just remove the cap
and the tether connects just as quickly
and easily you just pop it on
and you can keep the animal tethered
with no worries about discomfort or fit
and since the candy lock button is by
far the fastest and easiest method
and has extremely high success rates i'm
going to focus on it
for the rest of this webinar
here again is the shunting cap
and you saw it in brad's slide earlier
and this is just a very quick and simple
way to recirculate the bile
the cap contains a u-shaped tube which
connects the bio line to the duodenal
line
and as i said it connects magnetically
to the implanted button
and pierces each closed septum of the
bile button
which allows the bile to flow up and
over and back down into the animal
and the root is very short it's a very
short piece of tubing and the head
space pressure is very low so the bile
has an easy time flowing
while the animal recovers from surgery
and then because of the closed septum on
the button
you can remove the cap and replace the
cap without any worry about the bile
flowing all over the place when you
disconnect
bile is a slippery and unpleasant
substance and keeping your animal clean
is so much easier with this shunting cap
not to mention
connecting disconnecting and
reconnecting can all be done
in just a couple of seconds
while you're waiting for your rest to
recover from surgery you can set up your
cage system
biostudies are normally run in a
metabolic cage or a metabolism cage
in order to collect the rest of the
excreted compound which is found in the
urine and species
to adapt a metabolism cage lid for
infusion
and or bile collection you simply drill
two
two holes for the mounting plate and
screw the cage mount in place
with the two screws that are provided
you can see here
at the bottom of that aluminum pole
there's a little
mount with two screws it's super easy to
connect to
your cage lid the tether is then fed up
through the lid
and attached to the swivel and the
swivel is in a swivel mount in this
picture
the swivel is orange and you can now
attach an extension line to the top of
the swivel and run that line down to
your collection vessel
and you need to always
always make sure that your extension
line is extending to about eight inches
below your red
it's critical for uh bile collection
and i'll talk about that again
so the first setup for a bile study is
you're just collecting bile and if
you're only collecting bile you'll need
the bile and duodenal catheters to
connect to the two pins on a dual button
with a shunting cap for recirculation a
single tether
connects to a single channel swivel and
then you need the cage mount and
extension line of course
this is the easiest file study since the
setup is so simple
however you can only collect for about
24 hours max
before you need to reattach the shunting
cap and allow the rat to recover
many labs will not collect for over
eight hours without providing
replacement salts or artificial bile
via infusion into the duodenal catheter
the next option is bile and replacement
salts which is what i just
mentioned if you're infusing artificial
bile
you still need the bile and duodenal
catheters to connect to
two pantilock pins on a dual button with
a shunting cap for recirculation however
when you start the study you need a dual
bile tether connected to a dual channel
swivel
to allow free rotation of the animal
throughout the study
this time you need two extension lines
one for the bile collection and one for
the artificial
bile infusion when infusing your
artificial bile
labs routinely keep a rat on study for
up to 96 hours
i used to do this all the time but you
need to be infusing artificial bile
a study this long comes with it comes
with its own challenges
but with the can lock button there's no
issues with the catheters or tethers
detaching
and there's no problem with harness fit
you can also collect blood while
collecting bile and infusing artificial
bile
you simply attach all three catheters to
a triple button
and use a triple tether you then have
access to the bile and duodenal
catheters as described above
but you also have access to the venus
line as described
in the next slide
while you can have a bile duodenum blood
setup
this setup is more common when only
collecting bile and blood
you'll need the bile duodenal and
vascular catheters to connect to all
three pins on a triple button
as usual you'll use a shunting cap for
recirculation
and a dual tether connected to a single
channel swivel will allow the bile to
travel through the swivel
while the vascular line hangs out of the
tether
you can see it here hanging out with a
handy red catheter access port
for clean and easy access when sampling
that
line that's hanging out the side with
the red port is your
vascular line for taking samples and you
can't see it here but at the top of the
yellow swivel there is an extension line
that is collecting the bile you still
need the cage mount and the extension
line
of course but this setup is almost as
simple as bile collection only
and once again you can only collect for
about 24 hours
if you're not infusing artificial bile
salts
so now you know why you're doing it and
you know what you need to make it happen
you just need to know how to do it
so your rat is catheterized and it's
been acclimated to the fully connected
metabolism cage setup
when you're ready to begin your
collection you simply remove the
shunting cap and replace it with the
appropriate tether
you always ensure that the end of the
extension line is well below the rat
in order to create the essential siphon
action which pulls the bile up and over
the headspace of the tether and swivel
mount
i can't stress this enough once you take
the shunting cap off
keep the end of the line below the rat
some people like to fill the tether and
extension line with fluid in order to
encourage this siphon action but i never
did that
i was always worried about dilution of
the bile and the tether
but different labs have different
methods and all labs need to ensure that
the siphon action is never
impeded if at all possible hold the
connected rat above the system
with the with the tether angle down
until the bile has traveled well down
into the extension line
so that when the system is placed
upright again the siphon action
is maintained when you're getting a bile
study going the siphon action which
pulls the bile through the catheter is
90
of your problems you are you're going to
want to do everything you can
to maintain that siphon action
if you have a po dose you'll want
someone to hold the lid
and tether while you hold the rat for
dosings and because it's all hooked up
to the cage
if you're iv dosing you can leave the
rat in the cage and goes through the
catheter without it
it's in patency just send me an email
i'm more than happy to share
our previous webinar which covers these
topics in detail or we can email talk on
the phone whatever
i love talking about this stuff so once
your animal is dosed
don't forget that the bile still has to
travel to the collection vessel
you're going to have some untreated bile
in your first collection
fraction because you dose them and then
the bile that the animal has been dosed
the bile has to move
all the way from the animal into the
collection vessel so
you're going to have some blank pile in
there with your treated bile
so bile generally flows up to
nearly one
and a half mils per hour so you're going
to want to make sure you have the
appropriate collection tube for the
period of time you're collecting
you don't want to have too small of a
tube and overflow that would be
disastrous
unlike blood bile doesn't need to be
anticoagulated
and you can keep it on dry ice if that's
necessary
for stability of your metabolites
and don't forget once again you've got
to keep that collection tube
below the level of the rat ideally
somewhere around
eight inches under the rats
troubleshooting this is the most perfect
picture ever
and i love it so much so let's talk
about things that can go wrong when
we're running a bile study because if
you've ever
run one you know that things can go
wrong
suboptimal bioflow is almost certainly
due to catheter placement
an improperly placed catheter can also
lead to bile leakage catheter
dislodgement and stomach bloat
placing the calf
the other issues you might face with a
bile catheter include
creation of a false gallbladder which is
when the bile simply pools
instead of flowing out of the body uh
a bile catheter will never be flushed
i'm sorry merrill can you hear me
hi we lost you a little bit there so
could you start over on this slide again
um for some reason it's dropping here
and there
all right let's okay thanks
or not we might have lost her again
um okay i'm gonna take a pause here for
a second and see is
everybody able to hear me okay um i'm
i'm asking my
my colleagues here on the line i can see
that they can so
until merrill thanks um until merrill
can
jump back on in which case i'll hear her
voice and i'll jump out um i'm going to
try and keep this going for us so
um yeah so as uh meryl was saying uh the
first round of issues are catheter
related issues
um and so this has to do with how the
catheter is placed and whether it stays
in the right place and there you are hi
can you hear me now yes it's a little
bit choppy
it's a little choppy but let's try it
again i'll just
jump in if i need to where i can well
thanks for telling me i don't know
what's going on it looks like i've got
good reception here but
2020 am i right so anyway that's right
so suboptimal bioflow is almost
certainly
due to catheter placement i don't know
if you heard me say that but i'm saying
it again
uh an improperly placed catheter can
also lead to bile leakage
catheter dislodgement and stomach bloat
placing the catheter properly takes
quite a bit of practice
like brad said practice is going to help
you be almost perfect
and they've done thousands of
practice themselves so i highly
recommend purchasing pre-catheterized
animals if at all possible
some of the other issues you might face
with a bile catheter include creation of
a false gallbladder
which is when bile simply pulls instead
of flowing out of the body
a bile catheter should never be flushed
it's not necessary and it will almost
definitely cause damage to the bile duct
so never flush the bile catheter
you can flush the duodenal catheter if
need be
additionally use of an inappropriate
catheter can cause issues like
discomfort and damage to the bile duct
which is quite tribal
and remember i leads the industry in
catheters
and we're happy to help you ensure that
you have the best catheter for your bile
and duodenal surgeries
so if you're doing your own surgery uh
just ask
us for help with the catheter and we'll
make sure you get the right one for your
study
so the dreaded loss of flow
or the dreaded loss of sound again
great um okay i'll try again here
although this one is one that meryl
knows more about um so
some of the things that you can do if
you lose flow in the system
are forcing the rat to change position
so this might mean standing them up or
sometimes a gentle palpation of the
abdomen with your fingers
can help get things moving another thing
that you can try
if it doesn't interfere with your
protocol is a treat that can kind of
help things
get going in the digestive system which
is what encourages that bile to flow
and then if you are absolutely totally
completely desperate
you can very very very slightly
pull on the syringe with a line to
motivate the bile to flow
all right i don't know if i'm not you
are
okay i'm not trying to make things
difficult i don't know what's going on
uh so yeah you might want to move the
rat around a bit to get that flow going
sometimes the animals are super flexible
and they just position themselves in
such a way that
the catheter is pinched uh you can make
them move around
you can also try gently blowing into the
cage
they uh they like to smell your breath i
don't know if it makes them hungry or if
it makes them nervous but
it makes their bio flow sometimes so it
can speed up your flow
of course if you are allowed to offer
them a treat that can also get their bio
pumping
and as candace mentioned once you've
exhausted
every possible option you can if you
simply can't resist it use a syringe to
pull
the very slightest vacuum on that line
and you'll want to hold the slight
slight vacuum for a tiny bit
and look and see if the bile is slowly
creeping up and over the headspace
and then you want to ever so gently and
slowly release that vacuum
by removing the syringe this is a tricky
technique
and it can have dire consequences if you
do it wrong
so only do that as a last resort
and as far as speed of flow
i believe i've mentioned the siphon
action quite a few times
you really need to make sure you
maintain siphon action
if your rats are in metabolism cages you
could keep the vials on ice on the bench
or even tape them to the leg of the cage
stand you just need to make sure the end
of the extension line is below the rat
at all times if you're noticing that the
bile is getting dark
this can be a sign of stasis where the
bile is simply pooling
in other cases you may notice bright
yellow urine and plasma
and this may be bilirubinuria from a
damaged liver which leads to bilirubin
in the bile and the blood when this
happens there is usually an elevated
amount of pest compound
and the urine and blood so you need to
bring that
to the bioanalyst attention so they can
make a note of it
on the results and now it's time for a
case study
from gina i know we've spent the last
few slides discussing problems and
potential issues
but i hope i was able to shed some light
on solutions to those issues
and i hope that i didn't cut out too
much and make it difficult
but uh speaking of solutions to issues
it's now
time for gina to let us know about her
experience running those bio studies so
gina what you got
thanks meryl um so we are kind of
running out of time so i'll try to be
brief um this is obviously not me
in the picture but this is a colleague
of mine we still work together to this
day but
um this is just kind of an example of um
the some of the pain that we experienced
when we first started doing
bile studies um the buttons were not
available
at that time so we did use the harness
and you can kind of see the wrap there
is anesthetized in the harness so
we got all of our surgerized animals
from a vendor
we did not have the vendor put the
harness on so when the rat arrived we
had to single house them
to put the harness on you do unless
you're
really really good you have to
anesthetize the rat to get that harness
on
to disconnect your loop your duodenal
and your
bile loop hook it up to the harness as
meryl said it's very slippery
it's quite challenging to get the small
cannula onto the pin of the harness make
sure it stays on there get we also had a
jvc line because we would infuse iv
our drug iv to collect um
bile and then we would also sample blood
as well
so hooking all of that up took a little
bit of time and then we would just leave
the rat anesthetized
as you can see that line is well below
the rat um
my colleague kristen there is happily
waiting for the bile
to flow which as meryl also mentioned
can be
quite challenging so
i will just say again because we're
running short on time
switching to the button is been a life
saver it's the ease of use anyone can
really
disconnect the shunt cap put the other
tether on
and as long as you keep that line below
the rat
bile will start to flow everything is
much much easier i will say also
from a welfare perspective we've used
the buttons on both rats and mice and
we've also used the harnesses
if you've ever put a harness on a cat
i have a lot of cats they kind of go
flat and they freeze and they're
miserable
and if you've ever seen a mouse or a rat
in a harness they're also very miserable
because it's going around their bellies
going around their neck it's rubbing on
their neck and under their shoulders
it's very uncomfortable
i will say the animals connected with
the button
to the tether line there is nothing
going around their neck or belly
they look at least you know anecdotally
this is just my own personal
opinion they move about the cage
more freely they're less stressed um
with that if the rat is moving more
you're going to get better bile flow
you get usually less positional
occlusions
you don't have to you know go in there
and i've massaged many an abdomen to try
to get bile to flow
the other thing with the harness is your
catheter can slip off that pin
and if you don't catch it in time
then bile is just floating all over the
rat and you come
back to switch out your vials for your
collections and you find a big yellow
mess
in the cage and the rats just kind of
swimming around there in its own vial
in the fur so anyway i'll just end by
saying
ease of use for not only the person
doing the study so
again it doesn't have to be the same
person every time because the quick
disconnect
kind of i don't wanna say it's idiot
proof but it is you
take off the stunting cap you put the
tether on you wait for bile to flow
and then again the the stress to the
animal is much less
we only ran our bio studies for 24 hours
so ours were always terminal at the 24
hour time point
but as i mentioned you can recap the
animal put
the shunting cap back on group house
your animal give them a wash out period
replace bile salts and reuse them
so i'll end with that thanks so i went
over
and then i guess we'll probably do
questions
um if there's time
thank you so much merrill brad gina for
that informative
presentation and we will now start the
live q a portion of the webinar we have
time
for a few questions to be answered right
now
but we want to urge our audience members
to go ahead and ask that question
by putting it into the ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen
we'll answer a couple now and any
questions not answered
right now will be answered via email
so let's go ahead and take a look
because we have quite a few questions
already coming in and this has been such
a great
presentation today our first question
is how do you decide if you should
replace
biosoft salt or not and i think maybe
merrell or gina could probably answer
this question
i'll take it so uh when you're deciding
whether or not you need to replace bile
salts
if you need to collect file if your
exposure curve is longer than 24 hours
meaning that you're still seeing
compound in
the animal after 24 hours you you're
going to want to
keep collecting in which case you really
need to
be infusing artificial bile some people
just do a bolus
of um artificial bile on a schedule some
people
run a pump and infuse it in but
you need to do something really if
you're going to do it between 8 and 24
hours that's just a judgment call
by your uh your pi and your vet
they need to decide uh like at what
stage
is this study and is it more screening
and uh are they able to to do the
infusion it's uh
obviously it would be nice if every rat
got infused
starting at zero but it's not always
possible so
it's just a matter of uh what you need
according to your pi
thank you so much and we have time for
one more question
this question is for you gina does using
the catalog
button make it easier to train staff or
rotate them
definitely i mean you still want folks
who have an understanding of
the the bile study you don't want to
just throw anyone in there because even
with the button there can be challenges
as merrell said
just waiting for the bile to flow so
once it's connected again making sure
you keep that line below the rat it will
take a little bit of time
and it can get frustrating but again the
ease of just
not having to have two people or three
people in there
kind of anesthetizing rats and holding
rats above your head
of your head waiting for bile to flow
does make it easier to
to train staff and swap them in and out
again making sure though that you want
to
go through those kind of troubleshooting
things that can still happen with the
button but again in terms of
ease of use yes anyone can connect it
thank you so much and actually let's get
in there and ask one more question
because i want to make sure we get in
get and include brad in here
brad can can a lock buttons be implanted
in mice hi yeah
thanks for the question that is um
that's a great question and yes they can
so we have
seen and actually changed our standard
surgical exteriorization and mice to the
cannula buttons
uh mice are acrobats they can kind of
twist their head right around and tend
to get at catheters a lot
so we have started putting as a standard
um kenny luck buttons in all of our mice
and we've seen such an improvement in
patency
lasting out to you know 30 days plus
as well as keeping the catheter safe and
clean
so yeah they work they work amazing in
mice as well
i want to take the time to thank all
three of you meryl brad
gina what a great presentation and i
want to thank you for your important
research
i'd also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor
sai infusion technologies for
underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go i want
to thank our audience for joining us
today and for their interesting
questions and questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and you can view this webinar
on demand so lab roots will alert you
via email
when it's available for replay that's
all for now
take care until next time stay safe and
stay healthy
bye bye now
you